I'll be driving a heist in car the ix35  made by home blind and I'll be in this  the best selling electric car of all  time the nissan leaf we're trying to  drive to all terms of green technologies  all the way here from west london the  sky news studio to the conference in  Paris our own eco rally from the m25 and  the hydrogen seem to be holding up  nicely Tom cheshire currently plugged  into a charging point ahead of us but  we're catching him well we're almost  arriving in France we've had to come on  the ferry because hydrogen isn't allowed  on the tunnel because it's considered to  be explosive we've got three hours to go  to Paris but the good news is that team  electric is struggling to find charging  point there's the car it has about six  percent battery left because we got two  charging station and it wasn't working  that's not looking good what can i say  i'm so sorry time  you